You think the playoffs or a gift you get every year you think the guys at this game have a soft spot for those pretty?
hazel eyes
It's here, and it's gone boy one minute you're in the dance
But the next year on the timberwolves and just stuck prayin for ping pong balls for the rest of your forgotten
career
The Wizards are getting stronger
John wall is no longer a boy and they're coming for our rings
You're the best player and boris, and you're afraid of some scrubs from washing fell
dynasties for Lord Riley ah dynasties for
But you're forgetting one thing
We have dragons
My knees Meister cole said I'm out for the season. What if I never play again Busey
As the trade stipulates you must take one of my daughters my daughter Jody
My daughter Jordan my daughter Chris or my daughter
weasley
It's wesley
shut up, I
Soon will be your nice Russell the comic Russell calm down. Who's coming who's first?